WORKING IN TERAVAINEN TO THE
OUTSIDE WITH A SHOT.
KNOCKED DOWN STAAL WITH A JAM
AND IT WINDS UP SQUIRTING AWAY
HAMILTON AGAIN
HALF A MINUTE ON THE POWER PLAY.
NECAS FOR HAMILTON
MOVES IT TO THE CIRCLE
SET UP AHO
HE SCORES!
A POWER-PLAY GOAL FOR SEBASTIAN
AHO!
AND IT'S A 2-1 SERIES LEAD FOR
TAMPA AS CAROLINA PICKS UM THE
WIN IN GAME THREE.
SECOND GOAL, THIRD POINT TONIGHT
FOR SEBASTIAN AHO.
>> AJ: WHAT A GOAL FROM
SEBASTIAN AHO.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIS OVERTIME
GAME WINNER, THE CLENCHING GAME
AGAINST NASHVILLE.
THEY WORK ON THIS POWER PLAY AND
A COUPLE OF TIMES THEY HAVE TO
REGROUP AND BRING IT IN.
WATCH THEM BRING THE PUCK OUT.
JORDAN STAAL PARKED IN FRONT
BIG